oh man guys i just got the brand new
apple iphone this thing has such crazy
technology like a touch screen with
multi-gesture support wireless
communications and an ipod well guess
what it also has a camera and we are
going to be comparing the original
iphone 1 camera to the 13 pro mega max
ultra or whatever so yeah obviously this
isn't going to be as good as that but we
are going to leverage ai to make the
original iphone photos way better
we've got a brand new phone in the
mailbox waiting just for us we're going
to do some camera tests a brand new
iphone from russia wait is it really
from russia yeah
hey uh yeah let's go see if it's here
[Music]
studio foe
what the [ __ ]
um maybe it's in the studio three
mailbox
yeah
wait what the heck what is dude look at
all this freaking spam dude no one's
checked this for like dude like
legitimately this is post stamped for
2016 right are you serious
this is for jimmy jimmy has not lived
here in 10 years
jimmy we have your mail dude come get it
no new iphone a lot of old mail
that might actually legitimately be a
bit of a problem
here
no it's not here what i found a lot of
old mail there's mail in there for five
years ago guys
so regardless that means we do not have
an iphone we don't have the old iphone
or the new iphone
how we're gonna do this video
[Music]
from russia with love as you can see our
package arrived in excellent condition
yeah it looks like it just got squished
here and like just like the seal got
pushed outwards but this should be the
original iphone that was launched in
june of 2007. apparently it's already
been activated or maybe it's jailbroken
we're not exactly clear but hopefully it
turns on and hopefully it works
dude the russian hackers have already
had their way with this what if they've
installed spyware on this probably
literally like literally it was this
close to like just falling out of the
package it's pretty nuts to have in my
hand look how small
this iphone is
okay get that old camera out out of here
that's that camera's oh that's an 11.
hey where's my phone so this is an
iphone 12 pro max it is not the newest
one because the newest one literally
came out last week but for now you know
what we use what we have and i have last
year's model because you know what i
actually buy these with my own money and
i don't feel like spending 1200 on the
new one when i spent that last year on
the old one
this piece of crap old one
so this project is only a go if this has
already been activated and will actually
boot up to the home screen if i turn
this on and it wants me to activate it
in any form or fashion
chances are this thing's dead in the
water and we gotta regroup
yeah
we are in russian hackers thank you now
get out of my phone
okay there's so much that is archaic
about everything here but it's kind of
amusing how essentially the ui is mostly
the same notice how there's no other
screen there's no app store these were
all the apps that existed period no one
had an ability to create an app at the
time
no that's what i'm saying there's no
other page this is it where did you put
all your apps there were no apps that's
what i'm trying to say they didn't exist
dude this is a thick boy but it's also
just so small back when people didn't
realize they wanted huge phones the main
reason phones were so small back in 2007
is that people were went smaller back
then their hands have grown a lot in the
last 10 years the big phones came first
and the hands had to adapt same same
reason why people didn't have laps until
laptops were invented
the whole reason we have this phone is
to look at the camera but a bit of
context the first iphone had one camera
that was two megapixels the newest
iphones have four cameras that are 12
megapixels each oh my gosh it's like me
mom's first phone this is kind of the
camera under ideal conditions but look
how laggy that screen is there's so much
jello there's a whole concept called
rolling shutter it's the idea where an
image sensor actually captures it from
left to right over time a global shutter
captures the entire image at the same
time but that requires more energy so
most cameras today like 99 of them they
do what's called the rolling shutter
effect and we are seeing that hardcore
right now just with a little bit of
motion what should i take my first photo
of all of you all right first photo is
of nick
[Music]
we got jordan in the background too dude
is this what i would look like in 2007
okay okay so right away i'm noticing a
definite amount of motion blur because i
wasn't able to hold the camera super
steady and i guess that shutter was like
sure clunk as opposed to the new iphone
shutters which are like
i mean the screen resolution is 320 by
480 compared to like 2700 p on this guy
oh my goodness
so obviously the iphone one is old but
uh i wanted to see someone else's
opinion about it so hey guys uh this is
austin oh hi i'm just eating your
cookies oh man that was my cookie okay
all right you left it i appreciate you
okay sounds good that's nice that's
machine trained one iphone per cookie
that's excellent yo this is this so this
is og iphone right it is indeed the
iphone one was such a ridiculous device
like this thing was so ahead of its time
do you remember how exciting it was when
steve jobs walks out and goes it's an
ipod it's a phone it's an internet
communicator it's literally like one of
the best like keynotes i've ever seen i
go back to it every now and then just to
kind of like relive that moment you know
what he didn't say it's a camera because
uh
not good they got better over the
following years but it wasn't until i'd
say like from like 3gs that the camera
started to get decent but the iphone 13
pro camera this is the best camera setup
on any phone i've ever tried the main
sensor on this it's approaching a
one-inch sensor which is like what
you're getting like a sony rx100 is huge
and plus they've got the ultra wide and
the telephoto that they also need to
cram in here so the fact that the camera
bump is only this big actually is fairly
impressive so where do you think camera
tech on phones is heading it's almost
more so about the processing than the
hardware right because the real reason
why any modern smartphone looks good as
far as video or photos because of the
incredible amount of processing they're
doing to make the cameras actually
better one thing i'd like to try is to
compare the 12 pro max to the 13.
got it nailed it
perfect
perfect timing i was like oh you're
standing right in front of the water
cooler
[Laughter]
whoa
wait why is it so much more vibrant
comparing the fruit and like the table
it does to me look a little maybe over
saturated but it does look sharper too
look looking like like the details on
the glass so one of the things that is
new on the iphone 13 you have
photographic styles oh you can enable
essentially it's like having like
picture profiles on your camera so that
is probably part of the reason is i just
like to shoot with the rich contrast
because it looks a little bit crunchier
sure yeah i had to throw on a bunch of
like sharpening and exposure and it now
kind of looks more crunchy what is that
an iphone one over there you got over
here
yeah it is
[Laughter]
obviously a lot has changed with the
camera technology on the first iphone
versus the newest ones but i kind of
want to talk about that evolution a
little bit because we've started
deviating away from hardware upgrades
and started going towards software
upgrades behind the scenes that utilize
the hardware better than we ever could
have before i'm not interested in
comparing the quality of the original
iphone photos to the new ones obviously
the new ones are going to be better but
i want to know why the new iphone photos
look so good considering the sensors
inside the phones aren't we're going to
be comparing things like the resolution
how it handles exposure both
overexposure and underexposure how does
it handle motion blur how does it handle
rolling shutter these are all things i
kind of want to compare a new phone to
the original phone if we're going to be
running scientific experiments
i gotta address the part
[Music]
okay so let's do some science
so we're gonna go down to the end of the
street where there's an overpass but
while we get there let's test out some
motion blur shots and rolling shutter
dude this is the famous area look at
cmic over here right in the one wheel
except
with this kind of setting we're really
starting to test the motion blur because
the modern phone there's plenty of light
to have a super crisp image but the
original iphone i have a feeling this is
on the flight unless i'm super steady
the images i take here are going to be a
little blurry really pushing the limits
of dynamic range
i got to shop
[Music]
i'm gonna take an image like this
[Music]
let's see how it handles the power lines
resolution test we're gonna look at some
fine details like power lines is that
colby
that's colby this is a 37 millimeter
equivalent lens so it's kind of cropped
in we take for granted that just the
regular lens is so wide and that's
before we can go to the ultra wide
or the telephoto you know in the future
phones are just going to be littered
with cameras
so now that we did our outdoor tests we
should actually try to do some indoor
tests as well because there's not a lot
of light indoors oh boy this is this is
gonna be too extreme man that's okay
let's break it another thing that the
new iphones have is this thing called
night mode is essentially making a long
exposure now granted i know the iphone
13 photos are going to be better than
the iphone 12 photos
are they are going to be that much
better are they really going to be that
much better come on
so one of the things the iphone could
not do was play any games at all like i
find that really interesting because you
know on like today's phones you can play
triple a titles such as pubg mobile
today's sponsor yeah i mean we've played
pub g for years and pubg mobile is a
really great way to like play a full aaa
title on your phone wherever you are and
they've improved the touchscreen
controls so much back from when i first
started playing these type of games like
seven years ago all right so i'm
actually gonna boot up pub g mobile here
and tell you a little bit about the game
while i play
pogie mobile is a free-to-play game you
can literally download it right now and
play it without having to borrow your
mom's money
pubg mobile really focuses on the
simulation of war you know it's got real
world weapons and it's got some
realistic physics and stuff such as
weather conditions and like how the
bullet drops as you're trying to shoot
your enemies i mean there's lots of cool
updates too it's constantly updating
with new maps new modes and honestly it
looks pretty good it's pretty high res
like the textures are nice and good
looking and the new 1.6 update there's
also like seven new gameplay modes so if
you're getting bored well guess what new
gameplay mode such as survive till dawn
let's see if you survive till my dawn
this game was actually designed
specifically for mobile it's got
customizable controls training modes so
you can get up and running you don't
have to jump right into the hundred
player multiplayer rounds and like get
destroyed unless you're like me and
don't get destroyed if you don't like
how the touch controls work you know you
can adjust them you can change some
stuff out make it a little bit easier
for you to play the game or you can
connect an xbox or ps4 controller too
also it's wild is that pubg mobile has
partnered with dune read the books great
book excited for the movie and pubg
mobile has partnered with the movie and
speaking of collaborations they're
actually working with alan walker again
to bring you some really cool cosmetics
all right
i'm eating chicken tonight
for dinner because i won you know winter
winter chicken for for lunch anyway if
you enjoyed any of that check out the
link in the description so you can get
to playing pubg mobile as well but for
now we're going to get back to our
iphone 1 tests
[Music]
okay so we've taken a few photos i've
managed to get them onto the computer
surprisingly easy to get photos off the
original iphone i was led to believe
that was gonna be very hard first things
first what i'm noticing is that there's
a huge field of view difference between
these two phones the main camera here
shoots at around 24 millimeters this guy
shoots at around 37 millimeters
equivalent so what i actually realized
is that with the camera sideways like
this the horizontal field of view was
the same as we can see here right away
there's a few things that i'm noticing
one higher resolution now this is the
sort of situation where we're going to
see a very clear winner between the two
images it's like there is detail over
here in the original iphone shot but we
just have more detail in the new one
dude i found your new myspace photo
we're seeing this fold in your shirt but
over here we actually see the
cross-hatching pattern of the cloth
overall you view it wide it's a very
crispy image look at the original and
it's uh
crispy is not the word i would use
we see like just the tiniest of lines
coming across these top towers here
and those are just straight up
non-existent in the original we're
getting a lot more of like the specular
highlighted detail all the rough texture
that you're seeing in through here
especially right here in the black we're
not seeing any of that detail we're
seeing the large swaths of color and
contrast but no detail in fact there's
just a lot of noise instead the exposure
abilities of the new phones is going to
be drastically improved so you're able
to interpret a lot more light than the
original phone was able to do this is a
very good example of what i'm talking
about when i say dynamic range this
whole wall here is not in any sunlight
it's being lit entirely from the
environment and yet phone cameras these
days have high enough dynamic range that
we can see all that detail we can even
see a lot of the clouds in the sky
whereas if we're to look at the original
not only is the sky mostly blown out you
cannot see the pole at all and so you
end up with a very very crunchy photo
well i actually like the contrast on the
left so you actually really like that
conscious i do think it's still a touch
dark i'd want to lift it all overall but
this is an example of an unsavable
artifact we can't do anything about it
that is lost data and this is the wonder
of night mode probably my favorite
camera feature on the new phones damn
right damn exactly our eyes have a
stupidly wide dynamic range so when i
was looking at nick in the actual
workshop the image on the right here is
what it looked like to my eyes i'm just
not used to actual cameras being able to
capture that handheld
i look like a crazy mad scientist i look
like waldo's cousin wow look at that
crazy motion blur this one i was doing
like a twisty motion
incredible amounts of motion blur
surprisingly not that much on the new
phone you can clearly see the rolling
shutter artifact in here the ground is
all curvy whereas the iphone 12 very
very straight overall very very little
rolling shutter good here's a good
example matt was actually waving his
hand like this his hand is super crisp
no motion blur there and yet over here
he's got a blob for hands and then of
course there's a tremendous amount of
noise look at all this noise here if we
look at the uh iphone image there's a
little bit oh
oh
do you know what that looks like to me
i am seeing artificial intelligence
leaving a trail
it's not super smooth like i would
expect the noising to do we're seeing
some actual like lines of detail that
seem to just exist for no reason almost
like a waffle pattern i'm getting a
little bit of those little swirly marks
here especially down here above the
notepad it's weird because it feels like
it's adding unnecessary detail that when
viewed from wide creates this sort of
sense of detail being there it's weird
so obviously the new phone's cameras
look really really good but the images
look far better than what the hardware
should be able to kick out and the
reason for that is a bunch of processing
going on behind the scenes of the
hardware that we're gonna talk about
right now
okay so you may know about cpus and gpus
well there's a new type of processing
unit called an mpu which stands for
neural processing units it's
specifically designed to be able to
handle
huge data sets really quickly and really
efficiently that's all so that it can
execute on machine learning tasks what
does that even mean
machine learning is the application of
systems that can learn from their
experiences so that when it reads it and
identifies something that is similar
it's able to accurately guess what you
have trained it to guess so the chip
inside of the iphone 13 pro can
literally process 16 trillion
calculations per second using that new
npu in 2019 they unveiled the technology
called deep fusion because it actually
takes
nine photos all at once four of them are
gonna be very high shutter very sharp
anything that's bright it's able to
retain those sort of details it actually
takes four additional exposures that
allow you to kind of get some of that
detail in the shadows but with those
four exposures you're gonna get a lot of
noise in them that's going to change
between different shots so it takes an
additional long exposure image that is
able to actually kind of filter out some
of that noise and then it's able to kind
of recombine all those together to see
where the detail is highest and bring
that detail back so if i take a picture
right here
i can actually go through and see the
deep fusion pop into effect when i open
the photo boop you see it there it sits
there for a moment it processes it in
the background using those 16 trillion
calculations per second and then makes a
new image see how there's not too much
detail in nick's hair and then boop ton
of detail and i didn't do anything
that's just automatic and it runs in the
background every time you open a photo
which makes me wonder what would the
original iphone photos look like if we
were able to leverage the same type of
technology
there is a company called topaz labs and
they make four different programs and by
using a bunch of machine learning
algorithms and models that they've built
to enhance your photos so what i'm
hoping to achieve is a higher fidelity
image by running it through gigapixel
which will increase the resolution by a
factor of six i'm gonna run it through
sharpening ai to actually bring back a
lot of detail that existed in reality
but was not able to be captured by the
image and then if need be i will slap on
some extra denoising to really make a
clean
smooth but crispy image i'm actually
very intrigued to see how that's going
to work out and i'm interested to see if
we can fool anyone else here between
what's the new iphone and the old iphone
so i've gone through and i've processed
all of the images from the original
iphone using topaz's programs well do
you want to see some iphone 1 photos i
would love to see your brilliant
photography skills in action
that will clearly outrank anything that
the iphone processing can do your raw
skill will save the day
so on the left we have the original
iphone photos and on the right are the
processed ones in this photo here of
nick notice how like all of the motion
blur just goes away you can really see
the detail of the camera the canon logo
the esl even the vertical ridges of the
little twisty thingy really come back
and you can even see jordan in the
background suddenly his face is
perfectly crystal clear it's actually
generating new pixels by reading the
input image as like a reference
and it's it's creating new detail both
for resolution and sharpening and
denoising however when you start zooming
in that's when things really start kind
of breaking down this generated detail
it's kind of clay like yeah yeah it's
almost like a comic strip filter type
yeah yeah it's almost like you've drawn
over
what was originally there but what's
interesting is that when viewed from
wide it literally doesn't matter yeah
and it's because it's literally creating
these strokes of detail that maybe
aren't photorealistic but when viewed as
just abstract texture and detail it
makes it look more crisp it's a weird
psychological trick and it works that
iphone still was already surprisingly
decent with the ai upscale you could
absolutely call that a much more modern
still and unless you're pixel peeping
totally fine check out some of ren's
results all right so what we're looking
at on the left here are the iphone 12
photos versus the iphone one photos that
have been enhanced over here on the
right those are almost indistinguishable
from each other nice and crispy but when
we zoom in
dude mustache man
but yeah i definitely feel like there's
a lot more compression happening the
iphone because the data bandwidth is
probably not very high on it so like
things like the texture on the wall just
get compressed to a flat watch but you
know who knows how much the iphone 12 or
iphone 13 is cheating with its ai
upscaler too so i think what we're
learning here is that we can throw the
iphone 13 in the garbage thank you
where's that iphone one i need the
iphone one i need the upgrade okay yeah
i'll just take that with me cool thank
you new iphone
steve jobs got right the first time you
know perhaps to the iphone one man
i mean you're doing a great job
processing a two run
it's pretty impressive how good the
iphone one camera is it's not quite as
good as the latest iphone
but i really like the vibe of it it
looks like 35 millimeter film from a
cheap point and shoot i love it it's
that bloom and crunchy contrast that
really kind of gives it that sort of
like polaroid look it's cool to see how
far we've come but it's also i think
equally cool to see how far
post-processing has come and honestly in
some ways this has sort of more
character than shooting something on
like an iphone 13 everyone yeah so now i
guess ai has to start figuring out how
to add character and aesthetic
style and then we'd all be out of the
job so it's been really interesting to
kind of learn through experimentation
where the original iphone camera kind of
stacks up compared to modern cameras and
then where it stacks up when you throw
modern software at it a lot of the
camera upgrades that have been happening
on modern iphones do not actually take
place inside the camera they take place
inside of the processing unit and the
software that leverages that yes
obviously the hardware in these cameras
have gotten better significantly so but
i would argue that i think the future of
imagery is computational it's part of
why i was saying that i don't think the
actual camera sensor in my phone
is as good as it could be because it
doesn't need to be
thanks for watching